[Music]
all right big things are afoot over here
at team coco team coco now has a tick
tock and it's at team coco
david you're here to help us today yeah
can i just say before we get into david
i have been
the team and i use this term loosely my
team of experts people in their 20s and
30s have been telling me for a while
conan you've got to make tick tocks hey
i don't know what they're talking about
sounds stupid and and i know it's a big
thing out there but no i'm not making a
tick tock i'm a 95 year old man
uh and you know i did great things in
world war one to save our country and i
i resent
being told that i have to make a tick
tock when i don't even know what it is
does matt do you know anything about
tick tock i know what they are and where
they come from but i kind of that's all
i care to know and that's where i draw
the line yeah you and i are a similar
vintage matt and uh we aren't into this
tick tock wait a minute what i'm just
guessing by the look of you that you're
at least my age you're much older uh
yeah you're 38. sure yeah really are you
38 no
okay well still you got to moisturize
man you're falling apart you can make a
tick tock about that no well
okay you just piped up sorry i know you
told me to be quiet no no i i never
reveal that i tell you to be quiet
you're allowed to say whatever you want
what i was going to say to you
was that you could help us you could
actually as crazy as this sounds you
could actually be of help to us david
okay yeah you could be useful and help
you sound shocked that i could be useful
no i made it very cl don't sound shocked
i am shocked
you could actually benefit us this is
insane the world has turned upside down
tell us about this tick tock thing
well first of all it's super addicting
once you get started you're not going to
want to stop
um it's basically like a instagram but
just for videos
okay i know you're doing really well on
tick tock whether or not you know what
the team cocoa one i think is doing
really well i don't even know that i'm
on what do you mean i don't have i don't
make tick tocks do i you're on it how
could i be on it if i don't even know
what it is this is what we're talking
about there's now a team coco account
there's a team cook but what do they put
up i understand i thought a tick tock
meant that i have to be dancing and
singing with my daughter and we're both
embarrassing there's like different
sides to tick-tock for everything
oh i always thought it was people
singing into a brush uh some motown song
and you know a grandmother's doing it
and a daughter's doing it and a
granddaughter is doing it and it's awful
it's all awful i thought that's what
tick-tock was no so i mean that is
a side of tick-tock right but pretty
much any interest you could have like
there's a hashtag history talk for you
know you like history and it's just
people
giving history facts
taylor swift just joined tiktok
yesterday so swift talk is just trending
of people making videos about taylor
swift i swear to god i didn't know
that there were tick talks about history
yeah tick talks about music some of the
things that i might be interested in i
thought it was all performative people
wearing lululemon and doing like a funny
dance and then uh
you know clucking like a chicken and
pouring cheddar cheese on their head i
mean that's for sure part of it but not
every part of it okay well i would want
nothing to do with that part um
but i think that kids would agree
yeah i don't want and also i don't want
to embarrass my children any more than i
my parents my children are embarrassed
by everything i do so
uh i gotta watch that or they just won't
speak to me anymore you have 158 000
followers on tick tock i know but but
what are my tick tocks i don't know what
th what you're talking about so they
post like clips from the podcast clips
from your show different interviews
you've done
so we're all on this thing yeah on this
thing i left it on this
show
what is this contraption is it on the
radio
people like the big tick tock creators
will
buy mansions together and then it's just
all these people living in a house
making videos that's what i used to do
for instagram it's all repeating itself
get out now can i you know only the
platforms change uh yeah and and uh
wow that i didn't mean that to sound so
smart uh
that was throw out platforming but but
uh
you know i've
talked about this before but i worry
that we are a few years away from nobody
growing food
because
and i i wrote an article about this uh
once um it's out there somewhere i'm
trying to remember where i were it's on
tick tock it was on
[Laughter]
no i did i wrote a piece that i actually
really liked where i described a world
where
um everyone just got into
improvising and making videos and being
wise guys and the economy collapsed and
farmers stopped growing food because
they were making ironic videos where
they sort of pretend to grow food but
don't really and it's meta and it was
this is the total collapse of society
and it became very dystopian
i think tick tock is going to get us
there i really do i really think that
this could be the beginning of the very
very end yeah and david explain this if
instagram has the same features what's
the deal this one gets your stuff out to
more people so like here let me pull it
up because for example so there's
there's like a for you page and then a
following page wait what's happening to
that person is [ __ ] it's the first video
that popped up okay i actually have some
oh my god she's singing into her hair
brush and pouring cheddar cheese on her
head oh
it looks like she's in danger and is
trying to get help i don't know what's
happening so that's a filter on her or
what it's just her getting ready so i
think that's like her
niche that's what she does but then
there's also a following page which
you're actually not following anybody
just follow yourself oh so i see conan
takes jordan to the olive garden that's
a remote that we shot and um jordan
works for me and he's a big snob about
italian food so i took him to the olive
garden
and they posted that clip to your tick
tock and okay it'll go out to lots of
people okay we have some examples here
of of tick tocks too that are loaded up
is that right yeah that's right i think
i have something that i've done yeah
you've curated these yourselves because
we should mention that you yourself are
kind of uh tick-tock yeah is it too much
to say no no no what's the way is it is
it would i say david is this correct
you're quite the tick-tocker that's
correct yeah do you engage in
ticktackery
i do
really
he's been he's a known tip talker who's
engaged in skullduggery and ticktackery
i became way too addicted
to it over work from home to last so you
make these tick tocks mm-hmm what if
this turns into you showing us tick
tocks but it's an intervention for you
oh that's probably much needed we have
your family in the next room
they all pop up in the screen they're
not here they're not here for the
intervention they're just here for free
food that sounds right uh what um well
show us show us uh which one's first and
we'll describe it as we play it let's
start with uh so i started so my
roommate at the time jasmine and i
whenever we started quarantine we would
just drink wine and then we decided to
just make tick tocks after we'd had a
few glasses of wine so i think the first
one is like the first week i downloaded
tik tok of us working from home okay
let's take a look this is you and
jasmine getting drunk and making a tick
tock this took way too long actually
okay we're cutting around there's a
stripper pole was there a stripper pole
in your jasmine had it yeah she like
installed it into her and jasmine was
her roommate and so it's you two
and you're there's a lot of rapid cuts
of you and what's the song playing it's
to the fifth harmony song work from home
because we were working from home no you
were working it from home and this is
yeah uh i have some complaints the rug
the rug is very prominent and um it
looks just like a very cheap synthetic
shag
and um looks like it's mostly made of
scotchgard
[Laughter]
uh so i don't like that i think that was
new carpet too yeah well it's a great
color because it uh if someone vomited
on it you'd never know
[Laughter]
um
yeah that's my big criticism about this
tick tock is you know i think i'd be a
good tick-tock director because i have a
guy
i shouldn't engage in ticktackery but i
could be a director of aforementioned
talkisms and i could um i could tell
people lose that rug what's that thing
hanging in the background is that a bean
bag chair
um you guys are you know i would i would
i would clean it up a little bit the
lighting isn't terrific sure it was our
first one i'm sorry to be rough on you
it's okay yeah it's the first one do
most people drink a lot before they make
a tick tock i don't think so it's just
like what we'd like what else were you
supposed to do working from home was
this done during business hours yeah i
uh
i don't know i'll say you don't want to
say let me ask you one question david
you're my employee did you see any
cessation in payment um
during uh kovit were you being paid less
were you getting uh less money because
you were working from home you were
being paid in full yes sir yes okay
and so do you think it's possible that
you were making tick tocks on my dime i
wouldn't say it's not possible okay it
sounds to me like conan you funded this
and therefore get production credit
you're the producer of this tick tock i
am i whatever i'm i'm
i hear you're doing well on tick tock
and i bet 70 of the tick tocks you've
made have been under my employed during
business hours true or false true
then you owe me a cut but i always have
my phone ready in case you need
something
no but
you understand it's implicit that
between the hours
of nine o'clock in the morning and seven
o'clock at night
anything you do has to be
pursuing my interests well now it kind
of is because i'm showing you how to tic
talk for yourself oh nice nice david wow
you know i actually think this is all
the perfect setup we've seen one and
that we should continue this as a
cliffhanger
segment
okay next part yes we can't do this in
one segment this has got to be two
segments i am learning to tick-tock
along with matt gorley matt and i are
both uh elderly gentlemen but we are
learning the fine art of uh tick tockery
and we are being instructed
by um my uh my assistant david hopping
who's uh filling in for sonoma obsession
um and
you're going to teach us more in the
next segment and things are really going
to get crazy